hey it's me in this video I want to
share with you the top anti-inflammatory
cures okay so it's the key is isolating
what's causing the inflammation so let's
just cover all the possibilities number
one food allergies why because food
allergies can create inflammation so the
key is getting a log and finding out
what you eat and then how you feel right
after for example some people eat citrus
an hour later they're in severe pain
okay
or they might eat I don't know
nightshades and they get pain so you
want to keep a log and just write down
how you feel after everything you eat
and then you just isolate like what did
you when did you start feeling this way
what to do we have just before that with
me the sensitivity that I have that will
put me in the serious pain is broccoli
go figure I love broccoli but I can't
eat it it tears me up it used to be a
lobster and we just put me in bed you
know so so those are all things that can
trigger inflammation the next thing
we'll talk about is hormones most of the
hormone that controls inflammation is
the coming from the adrenal gland the
adrenal gland makes this hormone called
cortisol which is anti-inflammatory so
we need cortisol but not too much and
not too little and if you run out of
cortisol you can end up with all sorts
of inflammatory disorders that's why the
doctors give you prednisone
what is Brenda's own and cortisol it's
cortisol it's a hormone or they might
give you cortisone cream or cortisone
shots those are all anti-inflammatory
okay so that hormone is an adrenal
hormone I have something that I use as a
natural cortisone which is called
cortisol support this basically is great
for inflammation it's great for the
person that has arthritis bursitis
tendinitis chronic inflammation and pain
this is what this is for cortisol so it
just it's it doesn't have any drugs in
it it's natural but it supports the
gland that makes cortisol so it's a
really good thing
for inflammation okay so what triggers
what messes that up in the first place
stress so stress events will burn out
the adrenal so that's just one source
now the next thing is insulin okay
insulin if you have insulin resistance
you're gonna have a lot of inflammation
in the body now what is insulin
resistance it's a pre-diabetic situation
where the cells are not allowing the
insulin to penetrate so you don't get
the nutrition themselves but one of the
side-effects from either too much
insulin or insulin resistance which is
kind of too much insulin in certain
parts of the body is a lot of
inflammation so how do you fix that well
you stop eating sugar you stop eating
refined carbs okay breads pasta cereal
crackers and some people say well that's
oh that's really healthy for you well no
it's not very healthy for you it creates
inflammation so just cut that out and
you just might feel a lot better so
there's a lot of videos I have about
insulin resistance that you can watch
and you can reduce inflammation greatly
in your body so that's important number
three the gall bladder now this
typically occurs when you have
right-sided problems so I have people
that have like right-side like a finger
pain or a toe pain or a knee pain and
the right side usually that's
gallbladder and liver when that thing
doesn't work not only will it put
pressure on the rest of the organs and
kind of affect the nerves on the right
side but all of the anti-inflammatory
remedies that are listed you know or at
the health of storr are usually
essential fatty acids well guess what it
takes to absorb those essential fatty
acids a good gallbladder so again I have
other videos in gallbladder you can you
can watch on YouTube but that's one
source that you want to look at and even
like fibromyalgia people that have other
management's usually a gallbladder and
it's interesting because they don't know
it as the patient comes in my clinic
they don't know it's the gallbladder so
what I'll do is I'll rate the
fibromyalgia and then I'll just do a
little acupressure in the gallbladder
and then I'll reread it and it's
completely gone and it was blown away
they don't realize that our analogy is
referred from that darn gallbladder okay
and I might give them gallbladder
formula for that as well but
maybe I might just do some acupressure
so number four old injuries so if you
have old injuries like I do like in the
back or the joint or the wrist or the
elbow or the shoulder you had maybe a
old injury or a surgery that's now stiff
here's what you do you can take the
gallbladder formula but there's
something else you can do that will also
help you want to actually massage the
opposite joint okay just try it don't
even believe me just try it if you
sprained your right ankle and it's
inflamed work on the opposite ankle same
thing with the knee same thing with the
hip same thing with the wrist work on
this one just massage it wherever it
hurts on one side you work on the
opposite side and especially to your
shoulder okay but the key is you have to
massage the exact mirror image side
just try it it'll work okay that's a
little secret just between you and me
and it works like magic okay the last
thing has to do with soft tissue calcium
in the body
many people are even taking calcium and
they're feeling worse which is bad but
they have soft tissue calcium that
builds up in the joints it's arthritis
bursitis tendinitis they tend to get
stones and spurs and kidney stones and
heel spurs and tartar in the teeth in
golf stones and kidney stones so what
you need to do is you need to take two
remedies for that vitamin k2 okay which
is a maybe a new thing for you probably
never heard of it but it's vitamin k2
and then take vitamin d3 and you want to
take those together I like to take these
in the same ratio like this is 10,000
IU's I do 100 micro micro grams for
every 10,000 IU's so like I sell both of
these and I just I might give two of
each - 2 K - 2 D 3 and I would take that
in the morning with some breakfast and
then take that over a period of time
that's slowly gets rid of the soft
tissue calcium that could be causing the
arthritis that you caught that are
that's underneath the inflammation okay
so it's a soft tissue calcium so I just
want to kind of expand your idea on
inflammation in general so you can kind
of pinpoint what what you have a problem
with and apply some of this information
I will see you in the next video